Andrew had the difficult opening you are
pressuring pressuring gaining a slight
Advantage but then he played this move
Bishop to E6 a complete shocker for us
how would you explain this decision by
him
um I think I had a little pressure here
on Knight G3 move was very key probably
missed this move
um with the Dual threat of rookie 7
Knight H5 and uh you know I think here
it's quite unpleasant for black I see
what the computer says it's not maybe
not so bad but um I think um when you
see Knight five rookie seven sometimes
you know the pressure something panic
and play Bishop E6 yeah yeah it's quite
an Innovative defense when of course
unfortunately it doesn't work that well
how did you assess it once he plays this
move were you happy to see it on the
board no I was completely shocked I
didn't think it was possible but um yeah
once I took a closer look
um
I think white has you know not many
weaknesses there's not that many open
files for Rook so I assumed that um yeah
if I keep everything protected slowly
I'll why should convert this and I think
that's exactly uh what you did what was
let's say the last task that you felt
you had to do before you get the victory
in this end game well yeah so he played
A5 I played A3 um open day followed the
Rook Rook was coming in and um
so I think it was just a matter of
um how I keep everything protected while
he while he was trying to come in and
okay so I found maybe not the best way
but good enough
um
H4 G3 keeping it also he got his
structure a little bit on this side yeah
H4 G3 keep all the pawns protected and
like prodding his queen size structure
so I fixed all his pawns and I now I
keep everything protected and um okay
here I just made time control and then
slowly um
yeah why don't you convert this lovely
how important it is for you to get a
first round victory in tournaments in
general not necessarily in this one
um I think it's always nice to start on
a good note but uh you know I think
everyone probably has like nerves in the
first round it's very normal so it
doesn't mean too much it's but it's
obviously nice it's a lot better than
any other result guys any questions for
Andrew no just our congratulations
indeed and good luck with the campaign
to become the junior Champion yeah